Vũ 2 thê câu tỷ dí với nhau đã có mô tưởng tự trước đó, câu giáo bị bôi nhỏ trên mận sả hội.
Thế bảo lào đầu, sáng ngày 22 tháng 11, băng nguyễn tích nọc, sau viên chương trung học cơ sửa vận phong,
huyện sĩnh châu, tỉnh nghỉ ăn cho biết, bà vẫn đang phải sinh nữ giả su đau đầu, tróng bị bị đánh.
Chức nọc, nêm miếng trí tháng 11 ngày gần cũng chương ai bây tư, băng nọc, sau viên chương trung học cơ sửa vận phong,
tháng nhập phịt điều trị trận thương vụ đầu, mắt xấu bị xấu viên cùng chương là ông phạm phần đang đánh,
thách chính bài của bà nọc, nà vào ông phạm phần năng có mô tưởng linh quan để trịt bay mượt tịch bà.
Nhưng đến nay, hai đến công con đựng đánh dì nhau.
Sau đó, xấu thiện nhiều tại khoản phép bức ảo, năng các tựa dung phà dối là mấy dành dự như phẩm của bà nọc vào bột xún cá mộ, xấu viên chung ai chương.
Học đánh vào đối đau của vực chức tôi là hiệm muộn, điện đặt đủ điều,
sự giúp các khi gánh cá nhân của tôi, kênh theo các khi gánh phần cả,
tôi cảm thấy bị tự thương đặt nền, nhưng giờ họ lập thể khoản ảo,
nền không biết ai để tổ sát với các khoản chức năng, sau đó,
tôi có lên phép bức đăng một số lợi dung không nếu của thế cá nhân nào,
nhưng tôi là bị tổ cáo và sau đó bị kiểu lợi,
vì anh vui sử dụng một số tự lứt hiểu chình mực trên mật sau hội, mạng học mức xấu.